when you're starting off a business and
you haven't got a lot of cash and you
want to make sure that the bills are
paid sometimes it's a little bit tricky
to see the wood from the trees go right
this is the vision this was our
structure this is the game plan that we
came up with this year and I'm gonna
maintain it I'm going to keep on top of
it rather than just make sure the
money's coming in and that we're scaling
it's just about maintaining the game
plan team cohesively comes up with a
game plan at the end of the year my job
is to ensure that we hit that
hello everyone and welcome back to
another episode of the recruitment
mentors podcast I'm your host heisha
mizzouz and on this week's episode I was
joined by Roger Wilkinson we discussed a
lot about Roger's entrepreneurial
Journey as in 2007 he took the leap to
start his very own recruitment business
called the Ojo group so over the last 15
years this has been the business that
he's been building after only working in
recruitment for less than a year so as
you can imagine in 15 years Roger has
had to reinvent this business multiple
times but there was a pivotal moment and
that was in 2016 where he realized that
the business that he'd built wasn't the
one that he wanted always proud of or
was best bill or the success and future
success of the company so in this
conversation we really delve deep into
culture and how Roger over the last
number of years has rebuilt a culture
that he's proud of and a business that
he is proud of that's successful and
profitable enjoy the episode side Roger
welcome to the podcast thank you it's
great to be here
thanks for coming in despite uh I guess
yeah you said the whole whole team whole
family's ill so yeah yeah I'm doing some
serious night shifts at the moment and
day shifts but I'm here got some coffee
exactly I'm ready to go so look really
looking forward to to break down this
journey that you've been on like I
always
um like to do at the beginning
particularly for someone with the how
long you've been on this journey for I
think it's just really useful for people
just to have some immediate context
so obviously today like we're gonna
really focus on this entrepreneurial
Journey that you've been on
um because you started your own
recruitment business in 2007.
after working in recruitment for a year
that's correct right that is correct
yeah that's you less than a year less
than a year so yeah you you've been
building this business uh for uh just
over 16 years which is a long time
there's only two yeah you're going on to
the two decades Mark now so
like I'm gonna add some context here and
if there's anything that you want to add
or you think I'm missing then please do
but I'm just going to do some sort of
highlight things here broken it down
into sort of free key bits when we're
prepared for this so just to give
everyone a bit of an idea so end of the
first five years
um I put down here that you uh ended up
around 20 heads in the first sort of
five year mark
um and I'm not sure exactly what
revenues were but around a million I put
down here and then the next five years
so up into 2016 you've got up to three
million net fee income and around 38
people
now this is where it was a quite pivotal
moment which we're going to talk about
here where then you sort of ended up
going on this journey where you went
from around 40 people down to 12 to 15
people and you've been on this sort of
rebuilding Journey which is what we're
going to go into and then from that
point you've sort of been on this growth
journey of 40 to 60
um per year and you're now back up to
around
um no you're around 21 people now or
you're around 30 people yeah around 31
people now around 31 people hoping to be
around 50 by the end of the year and you
can continue to to grow revenues and net
for income so this is what we're going
to break down right this is the story
that we're gonna break down so I guess
let's just start with a million pound
question yep because I'm sure like
particularly with your model hiring a
lot of people that don't have
experienced grads you thought a lot
about this so what what's Roger's take
on what characteristics and threats do
you believe make up a highly successful
recruitment consultant in today's market
does the obvious ones which which
everyone's talked about like motivated
resilient
um but for me there's a couple of extra
things I think
you need to you need to have a level of
ambition that it could be that you want
to make the most amount of money it
could be that you want to progress
faster than anyone else you've got to
have that burning ambition to to do
better uh than than your peers
um and that could be you might be come
from a wealthy family you might come
from a from a from a tougher upbringing
but you still have that ambition
um I think you need social intelligence
um
I think to pick out a good candidate and
a good personality doesn't necessarily
need to be
um you don't need to come from a strong
academic background you just need to
have that intrinsically in you and those
are some key areas that I would say
make a difference for us and I also
think you've just got to be happy to
pick up the phone you've got to be able
to have it happy to have a conversation
if you're um
you don't have to be a total extrovert
um but you've got to be happy to do that
it's interesting to say around that
first bit because
I had Lewis uh did a conversation with
Lewis from wiser and the way that he
coined it then what you think about this
which I really liked was he found that
it's typically people that have a point
to prove
if you turn the externally might change
over time I used to have a an advisor
and he called it fear yeah he called it
something he he basically said you would
need to have this um almost nervousness
that that that
um
I think uh the ambition to succeed is
um just as powerful as as the fear of
failure um
and uh yeah that I I would I would say
that that's totally true I mean I know
recruitment companies that will hire
people that have to relocate that they
have no money they're they're kind of
risking it all and they've got to make
cash
um we don't necessarily hire for that
but at the same time I think that is a
that is a very motivating factor uh to
succeed
so less than a Year's experience and you
decided to go an entrepreneurial Journey
what what gave you the right to do that
where did that confidence come from
I think
um I think it was naivety mostly um I
came into recruitment uh wanting to set
out my own business
um and uh there was a friend of mine's
dad who wanted to partner with someone
so originally going to go into a
partnership with them
um and it quickly transpired that he he
saw it as more of an investment than a
um than a partnership so I bought them
out within the first few months
um
but I think the confidence to really do
it was was was probably more naivety I I
didn't really know some of those ups and
downs
um I think in in the long run it
probably held me back I should have been
in a bigger business I said learn some
decent structure
um and it would have it probably would
have accelerated my
um the business by at least five years I
think so if I was to be sitting in front
of you in 2007
like and I said Roger what what do you
want for the uh her group like what do
you want this business to be
what would you say
so right at the start I probably
wouldn't have had a very good answer for
you to be honest
um I would have just been trying to pay
the bills
um but later on we kind of compiled what
what we're about as a business
um and we wanted to be the supplier to
the top Tech innovators in the country
in the UK
um so genius style candidates
um really interesting Tech just being at
the Forefront of that the whole time and
that that that's that's what we want to
be number one for so you wanted to walk
quite early on then you had Ambitions
for it to grow wanted it to be
oh yeah we we've always wanted to be one
of the fastest growing companies in the
UK
where does that come from
I think that's just my ambition
um I wanted to make sure that I think
the recruitment there's huge amounts of
opportunity for people
um and
like I said you could you could make a
lot of cash but one big area I think is
that level of progression you can learn
some certain skill sets you can learn
some great management skills and you can
bring those skills into your personal
life
um to make life easier and better
um and if you're tying in with both
people that want to make cash and people
that want to progress
um you need scale and you can get some
really great people to work alongside
that maybe isn't all about money for
them but they they want to be running
and building a business
so why don't we why we want to get in to
review is this journey that you've been
on since 2016 and so what you learn but
just just really quickly
for for people listening that might have
ambition to start their own recruitment
business or might be early on
I know we're sort of going back sometime
here but obviously I'm I'm gonna assume
that because you did like you said you
didn't have that much experience there's
going to be certain things that yeah
just take you longer to learn or you
have to learn the hard way but looking
at that initial period
um in the first couple of years like
what what what ended up being sort of
um the sort of most surprising in terms
of you went into it like naively it was
like yeah I can do this I'll make it
happen but looking back what what ended
up being sort of really surprisingly
hard and difficult about starting a
recruitment business
so back then starting was tough you you
had to you had to put down five six
grand for a server if you wanted a
decent office space you were committing
to three years you were basically a
couple hundred grand of commits
commitments the risk of it failing uh
was just it was really scary and
nowadays it's just it's not that tough
um
but I think some of those structural
things that you can put in place that
that I didn't put in place we we succeed
in terms of billing we succeed in terms
of picking up great clients and
delivering really really well
um where we failed was building a
structure in place that when people got
three four years down the line
um we didn't have a bulletproof
structure in fact we had a bit of a
wobbly House of Cards
um so although we made a lot of money I
think although the candidate and the
client experience was actually quite
good we've everyone was like slightly
peeling off into different directions as
we scaled to the people part
yeah the people part in the management
part I think it's a lot easier to teach
people how to sell than it is to teach
people how to manage management takes
experience it takes years
um whereas selling you can you can learn
that aspect fairly quickly I think
so why don't we
because when we Pro uh prepared for this
and also like when you drop me a note on
LinkedIn sort of what really sort of
struck out to me which was interested to
speak to was like just this sense of
overall commitment to building a culture
that you're proud of yeah so why didn't
why didn't you describe the business in
2016 to us like why didn't you just just
take us back to yeah you got into the
office in 2016 how would you describe
the business then and you can take that
anywhere the culture the people what
you're about like why don't you describe
the business in 2016. so the business
I think had a
um High performing culture uh people
were making a lot of money the clients
were getting a good service the canvas
were getting a good service
um but on the management team it was it
was argumentative I would say
um and so we just started pulling off in
different directions and and it meant
that it was
um it was just less of a fun culture to
be in and for me I want to be in the
office I love going into the office it's
part of my sort of my structure and my
my framework for life
um and there was at times when it was
when it was pretty tough
um and
that part of it I would definitely never
go back how many people were in your
management team so back then we probably
had uh I think we had about six okay so
how how was how what was the structure
so it was like what you had directors
associate directors you have billing
managers yeah we have billing managers
uh we had one non-billing manager sales
director
um and yeah the rest of the team lead
stage and then myself
um and I think moving from so going from
one to ten as a as a manager as a sole
person you can manage 10 people as soon
as you get to 20 people that becomes
a little bit more creaky you need you
need a stronger management team in place
and as soon as you get to 40 you you
really need to be performing with your
management team making decisions by
themselves
um you might be the vision but but it's
it's really much more of a collective
and Democratic
um management approach as opposed to
that that probably autocratic approach
that that you start with
um and getting that blend right so that
your management team is making decisions
uh that are in line with
um your vision and values of the
business
um that takes time so that by the time
they get there and they're making those
decisions by themselves that that
they're making them fairly harmoniously
um I don't think you want a really soft
management team because
um you want people with a bit of heart
you want people to stand up and go come
on we need to we need to perform is this
good enough
um but you don't want people just sort
of shouting other people down so when
you say argumentative like what do we
mean here we're going to go into a
leadership meet and Rogers and go no we
should be doing this and someone else is
going no we should be doing that like
what did I actually look like yeah I
think I think
um and this is part of my upskilling as
well so when when you're a manager you
want to be asking like good open
questions and coaching people through
that
um and
a lot of the time depending on what your
promotion structure is which at the time
was for us was build pick up clients
um
it's much more comprehensive now so that
people that are reaching those
management levels are actually
um they're doing presentations on the
values they're talking about what
they've learned they're developing
skills so that they can sit around the
management table ask questions about
what everyone is thinking and then make
that decision afterwards so quite often
and you'll have this at a junior level
as well your your
um was in in the pub on Friday chatting
to someone he's like why did we take
away deal of the week I love talking
about deal of the week and we would on a
Friday we talk about deal at the weekend
we were just making a lot of deals and
it was so lengthy that I'm not sure
people were learning as much about it so
we checked we turned it into PD of the
week and talking about that side of
things and the successes but his opinion
was quite different even though as a
management team and a collective we
decided this was kind of the best route
for the business so you can have people
at kind of a junior level that will have
a strong opinion uh on on a situation
because that's their perception of it
um and if you're seeing around a
management team
table then you need to empathize and
understand before you've really stamped
that Mark on your decision you're you
you're listening to everyone else's and
you're not coming into that meeting
already having your mind made up so you
had okay she has a lot of people in the
room and there were got to the Top by
being selfish focusing on their own
performance self-centered they got there
by performing billing wise sales wise
exactly yeah which is which is natural
um um but I think when you're running a
business you need to make sure that
they're developing in other ways as well
so let's talk about them just on this
2016 period because
let's be honest there outside looking in
three million pound net fee income
Circle 38 people I'm sure you walk into
a pub and your mate's got all Roger
how's it going you're going yeah it's
[__] great making good money
um good size business so like what what
were some of the lagging indicators here
because obviously to go from then yeah
the the 40 down to 12 15 people we can
talk about over what period and sort of
how that manifested but I think what
what would be really good for people to
learn here is obviously you got to that
point and then you made some changes but
I'm sure you reflected on it like what
were some of the things leading up to
that point where you then had to make
some more drastic changes that maybe
people could learn from where they're
starting to recognize or pick up on like
oh you know what actually we might have
people in the wrong seats here or we
might have to work with this management
team to get better at empathizing and
understanding and listening to people
rather than just deciding and telling
people what to do so were there any sort
of one reflection were there any sort of
lagging indicators looking back that
maybe you could have acted a bit earlier
on or you to take an accountability and
going hey guys look I feel like we could
be doing better at this or maybe we need
to sort of start thinking about this was
there anything there looking back yeah I
think I think you I think you know when
things aren't working as well as you
would like
um because if you sit in a management
team and it's going it's going well but
you know your growth mindset you're
always looking for improvements to make
um you can tweak one or two things and
you focus on that on the month and you
really nail that process down
um if things aren't going that well and
you perhaps aren't
billing as much as you would like I
think now is a slightly tougher market
and that's when we'll start to see some
of these some companies Creak maybe a
little bit and see high attrition levels
is that you
um
everyone starts to have a solution for
the problem and everyone's problem is
every everyone's solution is a little
bit better than the other persons and
you've got a cherry pick which one you
really focus on and when you walk out
that management team everyone's got to
get behind that decision and if you've
developed a team which
as soon as they walk out that room
they're kind of up for it and they're
gonna
be up for that challenge and they're
going to move forward irrespective of
whether or not they necessarily believed
in it and I think you've got a pretty
good winning formula if you walk out if
they walk out that room and people are
like oh I'm not sure that's not what I
believed in and then you've got a
formula that could uh it's probably
gonna not end very well for anyone and
so
um
there'll be plenty there's plenty of
warning signs but I think ultimately it
comes down to is your is your Workforce
harmonious
um is it happy is it is it improving do
you have those constant small steps
forward
um
it might not be the perfect solution for
everyone but are you constantly moving
forward
okay and then was there was there a
moment then that you were like looked in
the mirror and thought
not proud of this business not happy
with what it looks and feels like
um so we had a couple of sections to the
business in London and I was starting to
open up uh separate sections of the
business and open up a Scottish office
and there was a period when I get a
phone call from literally being in
Scotland for two days and um it was like
most of the world's crumbling kind of
you kind of almost need to come back
down I was thinking I've made a mistake
here
um that sort of adage that you you're
not a leader till you've taught a leader
who can teach a leader I I was I was
Miles off that
um and
and I think that was a point where I was
thinking okay well I've scaled the
business to a certain size I've got
overheads and this this might be true
today where there's some businesses that
maybe haven't nailed down some of their
practices
um perfectly they've scaled in the good
times
um and you get to a situation where
[__] I've got a lot of overheads here I
need to make money
um I don't really want to take a step
backwards because I've never really done
that in my life
um how do I ride my way through this
um and that's a that's a tough
realization that if you're someone who
always wants to move forward you might
have to take a few steps backwards to to
go forward or or it might be enforced on
you so the realization was then what I'm
getting is the business even though it
was at that size it had a management
layer was still very much reliant on you
and wasn't capable of running
self-sufficiently without you
yeah I mean they were they were great
performers in their in their own right
but as a as a team that was pulling in
the right direction to achieve the
numbers we needed to achieve and just
hitting our goals
um it wasn't happening and then and then
you get people
um it's possible to have able to blame
culture then okay so uh yeah so look I
want to go into then
over the last few years but just just
really quickly on this then yeah because
I'm sure you've reflected on this yeah
yeah like for me I'm I'm big into
um personal responsibility like you said
there then the blaming I don't think you
can get anywhere in life by having a
victim victim mindset and not taking
accountability so when when you look at
that period then like as a Founder as
the the person that was driving that
business forward made the decision to
hire these people made the decision to
promote these people like like where
where do you think you fell short then
I think
I didn't have a great promotion code uh
structure okay so I wasn't training and
developing people in areas that um
that I now know to be critically
important and I can see it happening now
at Mile off uh with the with with uh
with teams at the moment I'm thinking
okay this could lead to this which could
lead to this um so just keep an eye out
for it
um
that structure was important so
what you want is between promoting
people on your values
um one of ours is it's humility so
um
we won't have that situation where
you've got someone who's like total kind
of arrogant [__] that's pushing
people down to lift themselves up
um
which I probably allowed allowed to
happen because I was promoting this like
high performance hair we've got someone
who's just had like 20 30k paycheck and
uh and they're totally killing it in the
marketplace
um and I was Fanning the Flames if
anything
um so
um so yeah I I wouldn't I wouldn't go
down that that road again
um there's a bunch of things which which
I know
that I shouldn't have promoted people as
quickly as they uh they should and It's
Tricky if you're hiring with grads
um and you want them moving forward and
you don't want any speed bumps you want
them to accelerate through you want them
to be managers as faster than anyone
else because that helps you hire that
helps to demonstrate hey we've got
superstars in my team
um
but really it's it's it's it's it's not
good for anyone just end up having
attrition everyone gets frustrated
you're stressed
um and the performance
um in the long run is it's it's not
going to help anyone I appreciate you
sharing that so so where where did you
start then like obviously recognize
actually yeah maybe I've done some uh
thing um a few things wrong here or I've
obviously learned from them
I feel like I could be doing this better
I feel like yeah we could be
um we could have a better culture we
could have better people in the right
seats like where where did you start
here then so when we said yeah like then
went around sort of 40 down to 12 15
like was that over a long a long period
or like where so where where did you
actually start uh
it was pretty quick when I decided that
the Scottish office is not really
working I need to come back to London
um
um and need to basically almost Go Back
to Basics yeah um and the start was sort
of it was almost my way out the highway
this is we're just going to make it work
and we're gonna we're gonna outperform
anyone
um and we just went back to that and
there was some a lot of
um
hard conversations with people and are
you on the bus because we're going to
make this work
um and are you up for it and some people
really were and some people some people
really weren't
um so
I remember having a conversation with
Joe
um sales director at the time and like
we need to go we're gonna go we're going
to scale down we're gonna go to a new
office
um there is blood on the walls in this
place uh let's move out of it go to a
new office but when we go in there we
want to have deals Galore coming through
and we're just immediately going to
create positivity and and we worked our
ass off for three four weeks and as soon
as we got in that new office
um it was actually probably a little bit
longer than that because we had to sort
of see how at least so it was it was
about six weeks when we decided to do it
and we've been working really hard up
that point so we left that old office on
a little bit of a high and there was a
buzz going on
um and when we hit the new office which
was much smaller
um we were kind of a bit more crammed in
there uh rather than looking at all
these empty seats
um and um it immediately changed and
from that point it became a movement
forward that we
um that we had more of that hockey stick
uh graph where like okay let's take a
little bit slower at the start let's get
it right let's make sure the processes
are really nailed down and that each
person is
is good before we move on and we start
hiring again
so okay so then so basically you just
want it so basically you just yeah like
go your house in order
got the right people on the bus on the
journey
and then it was like right we're gonna
go again new chapter new sort of season
uh of the Idaho group
um
but when it came to obviously if
obviously you like looking back it was
the leadership team management team
including yourself in that they didn't
quite end up working why don't we just
focus on that for a second like when
then the the moment came of like okay
well let's let's start growing we're
getting some good success we've got a
high performing team
what is it that you did that was
different this time in terms of
promoting people you said they're around
promoting on values what was it that you
like right okay well when we do promote
people when we do have people more in
management seats what are the
non-negotiables now compared to yeah
obviously when it didn't quite work out
so
um one of the things I started to do was
was higher experience or at least have a
a flow of experience coming through
um because if you're just a purely
graduate model and someone leaves from
the top unless you've got someone that's
ready and waiting to step up and I think
you're in trouble because you then get
this right of passage where people kind
of expect to be there
um and you do need a little bit of
outside outside exposure
um so
um that was one side of it
um in terms of the development piece
every quarter will have a promotion
meeting
and everyone will score themselves
against varying values and that could be
as much as like system work or
um
values in the business let's call
themselves out of 10 and write a little
little blurb on that and then there'll
be some managers comment on it and
whatever they're focusing on as well as
our headline promotional goals will
probably be some softer skills that
people are working on we still need to
do before they get promoted
um and those opportunities every quarter
that you're that you're sitting down and
chatting with people and developing them
as well as doing it on desk you can kind
of look back and see that Journey that
people have gone on
um and that's something that as a small
business and starting out it's very easy
just to build pick up clients and
recruitment it can be it can be 20
blokes in a room
and the difference between that and a
really well organized business is these
processes that you that you nail down
the rigor you put into it
um making sure that you're having a
formulaic starts and ends to the year
and mid-year reviews those sorts of
things are really critical even when
you're a smaller business
so how do you promote someone on values
you're not purely promoting someone on
values you're just probably not
promoting them as quickly if they don't
hit your values okay and so if
um
if one of our values is motivated and
you've got a
you've got a contract below or someone
who's has a great client they hit all
the Billings
but they're not really challenging
themselves and moving forward although
they've hit that that that that number
it might be that you're actually saying
to them at an early stage Are You Are
you delivering Are you delivering enough
to be a senior here Are you delivering
enough to be a principal
um because
I'm wondering where you're at and we
would often score people we will allow
them to score themselves on a monthly
basis how they feel their input visits
their output is out of 10 so you can
kind of see what they genuinely think
and that decision gets kind of kind of
made for you
um so it's not necessarily that you're
trying to hold people back
um
you're trying to get the best out of
them to perform and that promotion that
increase in salary and that next step
for them
um if they're not going to work for that
and they're going to Coast
um it's gonna
end up being that they're not going to
enjoy it in the long run they need to be
improving and that's I think the
structure of what a promotion criteria
should be should be about hey everyone a
real quick one from me this podcast
would not be possible without our
amazing podcast Partners Vin cherry and
Source breaker because you listen to
this podcast you're able to get your
hands on exclusive savings on both of
these award-winning products if you're a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out vincere who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with Source breaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
Source breaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products so it
sounds like you you utilize like
scorecards and things and so like for
example if I'm in your business you said
humility errors if I'm in your business
I'm a permanent recruiter and to get my
next promotion I needed to do
consistently for the last quarter 15
grand per month
um how how do I I'm just trying to
understand because it'd be helpful for
people because this might be something
that more companies want to do yeah
obviously promoting someone on their
performance is just way more easier it's
like it's in black and white yeah which
is why that's how typically people do it
so like how how are you then measuring
my humility like how are you then is it
like okay so each month he should screw
yourself out of 10 on how you think
you're living our values and humility is
one of them I'm gonna go you know what
eight out of ten yeah how do you then
measure that is just completely
subjective it's it's their own it's a
tricky one because if they put 10 out of
10 for Humanity yeah you're like right
it's not very humble but
um uh it's down to them and it could be
that you're actually going on a second I
I think this isn't quite right here is
it and having a sensible conversation on
it and then there might be some example
cases where he said okay look this was
this situation this scenario
um this has happened a few times
um how do you think that impacts others
um okay what do you think that does to
the business
um this is an error that I wanted to
work on
um let's make sure that this happens and
then you're reviewing at the end of it
you need to give people plenty of
warning plenty of opportunity to improve
it's much more about that gives you a
structure to a Clarity that people can
work to but it's the on desk bit that
really makes you sit okay because you
don't want to get to a promotion meeting
and say sorry I met you failed uh
because you bit of an Arrogant Bastard
that should be totally clear beforehand
yeah exactly
so why why don't you I always talk
because I know this is sort of what
you're passionate about then so what
else did Roger intentionally do culture
wise
in sort of rebuilding this business the
way that you wanted it to be it's a lot
worse we've spoken about the promotion
criteria promotion promoting people with
the values you also spoke about
um getting more entry um sorry getting
more senior people into the business so
then if you did have someone leave then
you don't have someone with six months
of experience going Roger I'll have that
promotion please like I think I deserve
it like what else what else have you
done on this journey to be really
intentional around building a business
that you do walk into and go you know
what this is this is excellent this is
the type of business that I did one this
is a better functioning management team
what else did you do really
intentionally then on on the culture
side within the business
um
I mean there's loads of little things I
think
to a certain extent when you're talking
about culture
if you're having to have a lot of
conversations about culture you probably
haven't got the best culture
um but what you do is you just put you
put a bunch of things in place and it
will it can make a huge it can make a
huge impact
um so
um we have a lot of feedback sessions
um
I'll have uh once a quarter Rogers
Roundtable where would you go for a meal
have some pieces together and talk to
different people in the business about
what their thoughts are rather than just
chatting with the management team
um
for me
that office environment should be a
really healthy environment it should be
a positive environment and you don't
want people
coming off the phone chatting to a
client and go oh for [__] sake it's
such a wank that just that just breathes
a little bit of negativity so you don't
want them being negative towards
candidates or clients
um you want to keep that a positive
environment and then you want you want a
healthy body in mind so we'll do things
like last year we got a personal trainer
in place
um we did Three Peaks together uh I
didn't think that I'd be climbing three
mountains with an amazing bunch of
people but it was genuinely one of those
kind of
life-changing events to the point where
we're doing it again we're doing
something this year where we're looking
at um uh taking a group of us or whoever
wants to do it um uh up to a mountain in
Slovenia and um
and we'll do that on a weekend
um
we'll put a bunch of different processes
in place
whether it be having breath work
sessions uh talking about health and
fitness and diet
um just creating a really high
performance culture you can have someone
performing really well who sits at a
desk for 14 hours makes insane amount of
phone calls and they bill a crazy amount
but I don't think that they'll I don't
think they'll keep doing that at some
stage they'll kind of go what am I what
am I doing in my life
um so create uh create that structure
and that Foundation it's that skeleton
which people can really live by and when
you're hiring grads a lot of the time
they're coming from University it's the
first time in an office you really want
to demonstrate okay this is a
sustainable way to live your life
okay so all sounds great
how does it how does this positively
influence the management meetings that
you now have then
I think you just got a happiness on the
floor
um if you've got
a situation where you you you're having
to say
get on the phones you've got to hit this
kpi you've got to hit this number and
and it's a frustration running through
the business
um
then then you're gonna have negativity
if you can create an environment where
um it's like having sort of a Lead Sled
Dog versus a chariot with the horses and
they're almost pulling away from you
there's times when you need to be that
Lead Sled Dog there's times when the
managers need to be that lead select dog
but if they can create that high
performing culture then they end up
being standing on the Chariot with the
horses pulling away from them and you're
just steering in the right direction
um that was an analogy from Roy Ferguson
he always liked that one um but um
that creating that happy environment
will create a high performing culture
it's
it's I think it's you can make money in
a toxic culture
um but it's always a it's always a bit
short term
so if they're the sort of things you do
now then what sort of things are you
doing in the past then just what lunch
and like just piss-ups every Friday like
what yeah we still we still have a bit
of a piss out we still have missing
yourself restaurants and all the rest of
it um but
we've last Friday we had a goal which
was
um
which was if teams didn't hit a certain
goal then we would all go for a 5K run
together okay um
that just would never have happened
because everyone I'm not doing that
um and everyone was kind of up for it
and a bunch of people walked it
um and it was kind of totally
you had to be up for it but at the same
time everyone everyone was up for it
everyone who didn't hit was up was up
for it it was just a little bit of fun
stick
um uh we have a lot of carrot um we have
a bunch of different targets and
holidays and all sorts that you can win
um the whole time but there's you also
need it you do need a little bit of Step
you need people on board with that as
well
um you can't have people say I don't
want to do that
so how have you how have you now got
better than uh
uh how has Roger created leaders have
you done nothing because it sounds like
that's what you struggled with in the
past
yeah it's it's training from an early
stage it's train train develop develop
so we'll have a Future Leaders program
and that runs two quarters of every
every year
um and they will run a team uh of the
Future Leaders together and they'll run
and perform and have some targets which
they lay out they create a budget on it
they perform together we we discuss
um how to motivate people how to get the
best out of people
um difficult situations that people have
got when they're running weeks um and
someone might be in that from
under a year with us and by the time
they get to a manager they've probably
done two years worth of experience of
actually
managing by the time they get there so
it's just about training and development
so that by the time that they get there
they've got a lot of exposure and a lot
of experience we also have an advisor
that
um spends an hour a month with them to
talk through some of those
um
management and career development pieces
so they just have that period of
one-on-one one one-time coaching that I
think helps help support them
um but just an outsider's point of view
as well
um I think those are the major bits it's
it's it really is just a development
piece if you stick someone in a role and
a sink or swim
um
going to be a bit stressful for for both
the manager and the person doing it it
doesn't mean that they won't succeed it
just might be a little bit more
stressful no yeah so common I
um
I think one of the most underserved
communities in the recruitment industry
is that leadership layer yeah there's so
many people were just sort of yeah
learning as they go in that role pissing
people off being ship managers before
they become good ones
um and it's really difficult no one
really gets taught how to coach they
just get taught how to tell uh exactly
so I understand that you're trying to
equip people with the skills before they
even get there
so it sounds like yeah you've obviously
partnered with someone or outsourced
part of that or do things but like what
what is there anything that you've done
you think better this time around
obviously you you've clearly invested
advise of these things for people but do
you think there's anything that you've
done to set these people up to win
rather than than fail
when you're starting off a business and
you haven't got a lot of cash and you
want to make sure that the bills are
paid sometimes it's a little bit tricky
to see the wood from the trees and go
right this is the vision this was our
um this was our structure
um this is the game plan that we came up
with for this year and I'm gonna
maintain it I'm Gonna Keep on top of it
um rather than just make sure the
money's coming in
um and that we're scaling um that I
think for me
it's just about maintaining the game
plan the team cohesively comes up with a
game plan
um at the end of the year then it's my
job is to ensure that we we hit that
and then how have you structured the the
leadership team now then have you been
conscious of
how many people
um manage like these types of things
because we did
our recruitment Mentor who did a bit of
a sort of insight and performance survey
on our customer base and I think one of
the sort of always sort of struggling
areas we're just talking about that
leadership team I think a lot of people
find themselves
managing seven eight nine we had some
people say that they managed 10 people
while still having a number and we found
that the sort of average recruiters to a
billing manager um ended up being around
five yeah so how have you approached
that that leadership uh layer out of
Interest yeah so I mean last year I saw
that problem happening so we brought in
uh an experienced hire
to um to support the younger managers to
make sure that actually they aren't
getting swamped and that development
piece was there um it's just having
enough hierarchy to support them but not
so much hierarchy that those those top
spots are just getting taken up so they
don't have the opportunity to to scale
and and to to be you know one of the
integral people in your business
um
that I think is the key it's just giving
them the support and the framework to be
able to do it and then keeping on top of
it as a manager I think if you don't
check up on it just expect that it
hasn't been done and so if you put
something in place
um or you come up with a strategy then
just keep on checking up checking up
checking up checking up
um that's critical
so let's switch the gears here then
before we um finish I know obviously a
big thing you want to talk about was
cultural right I feel like we've spoken
about that yeah
um yeah and I appreciate you sharing all
that I guess look definitely top of mind
for a lot of people but from what I can
see online in our conversations it seems
like uh I don't know exactly when you
started but let's talk about us
expansion and sort of what we've learned
there right because I know that's
something that
um you've been really focusing on or has
been part of the the business journey in
more recent times
looks like you've been focusing on
Austin Texas yep what's been difficult
about that so far
um
just wish we did it sooner really yeah
I think it's not as easy as people think
um
probably
I've ended up working really long hours
supporting the US team because it can be
tricky when people
leave the office at six seven eight and
you've got a US team that's a small team
that's that's there until that to the
latter hours
um
but so far so good I mean
to be honest they're both
the two people regarded two top builders
in the business at the moment so and
that's when we're standing start so
um what was the go to market then what
was the game plan
so we just kept it super Niche
um to start off with So the plan was
just
support but we had
we didn't actually really have any
clients out there just one person was
like I want to do this and I want to go
to this location I'm like there's a good
Market there I know there is let's go
for it
um so we just kept it one area
um not one person we put a couple of
people on it we want a couple more in
the team now
um
and just keep focused on that really
tight area to start off with
um and we got given roles outside of it
and we just haven't really worked it
we've just stuck on that tight area and
it's having a combination of I think
few little cards are scaling and just
one Flagship client as well and we
managed to nail that like really really
quickly
um
this first deal
well actually was another team that did
a deal
um sort of randomly
um
that that was kind of before we'd even
launched launched it and right it was
just a contact that said can you do this
and we're like okay well we're launching
so let's give it a go we ended up making
two or three Deals there
um but I think it took him
two months maybe okay it was a bit
slower than we initially planned like
that we started last year and that Q4
was a bit a bit lower than than we would
have hoped a little bit and then and
then it's and it's really accelerated
since then
so what have you been my surprise by
there then
um
think
how
much money you can make
um I I think it's not as easy as people
think I think there'll be a lot of
graveyards everyone trying to swarm to
the US
um and especially if you're putting one
person on it and going here you go good
luck because you're taking someone who's
probably experienced you're having to
invest in you're going to want a minimum
two but maybe three four people going
after something um you've got to expect
some spend some cash on it
um and
I think it's probably not as much about
picking up the phones and hammering it
uh I think that
um you do need to be able to pick up the
phone you need to speak to a lot of
people
um but you can mark it out and and pick
up clients that way
um
I don't think
I don't think the US particularly like
working with UK based clients I think
they would much prefer if you were in
situ oh really
um yeah and and I think I think that
those those working hours are
they're they're a challenge I think to
get people that are just really up for
working that late into the night
consistently well yeah I think there's
got to be
I've spoken to people and that's been
the real challenge particularly if you
have
I speak to one guy who there's one
person in the team doing it with
obviously the plan for more people to do
it but you see the UK team living at UK
hours or you know they have a six or six
side Team game that you can't go to
because you work in Us hours and you're
the person that's only doing that
difficult yeah yeah I think the person's
got to want to do it you you
you need to have someone that's
that wants to go to that location and
wants to do it if there's any doubt in
their mind you're gonna you're gonna
struggle you want someone who's
passionate to go out to a certain
location
um
make it happen there's definitely a lot
of opportunity there so if you mentioned
money a lot then what what's what's
ended up being like the average deal
size
I think it's about 23 Grand something
like that and whatever the terms that
you've agreed been a lot more because
typically when I've interviewed people
around it it's been yeah you you're way
more likely to get 25 30 times agreed
yeah I think that's creaking a little
bit now
um so
um we were just chatting about it last
night actually there was another new
client that we picked up and we put
across 30 and then when uh it's 18 and
then and uh and I think they're having a
conversation with them today
um as to what that's gonna
end up but we're sort of building a name
for ourselves at the moment I mean I
don't really don't want to go below 20
um
but um there's some different things
like you
you can't ask you can't ask the
candidate's salary
um just some
um legal things that we probably weren't
as aware of
um before we started if you had the um
the other common one that we've picked
up on here has been the working job that
you haven't got signed terms for
um yeah or even just I've heard that you
can
if you put an advert out for a contract
role and it's a certain rate and you and
you end up taking one on a different
rate you could get super certainly yeah
yeah you've got to be a little bit
careful I think because
um uh litigious Society so what what's
just find a bit on this and what what do
you think has really worked so far then
so obviously having the need having a
focus and just doubling down on that
yeah anything else that that you found
just obviously from your perspective
been doing
um obviously a viewer has done the UK
market then or different sort of EU Mark
EU UK yeah pretty much entirely UK yeah
so we're from outside looking and then
what do you think they they've also done
well besides just having a real Niche
and focus that that's gone down well
that's helped them get Traction in the
US do you think
I think is that perseverance is that
belief that is out there you've got to
understand the market you're gonna I
think it's very easy to Market map these
days you take out LinkedIn insights and
see exactly who's hiring where the
attrition is you know you can you can
kind of build and you can build your
Marketplace really really quickly
um
but um
by building a database of candidates
um it takes time you need to you need
people that are
probably want to get out to the US and
want to get out there as quickly as
possible so they're putting together a
really good plan it's a really good well
thought out plan and it might be that
you're not just going straight after
clients that actually you're going after
candidates
first
um it's chicken and egg grill isn't it
um and as soon as you've got that first
piece of business you're really making
sure you deliver a a exceptional quality
so as we can come to the end here
obviously being on pretty lengthy
Journey yeah like
obviously we've spoken a lot around
leadership culture speaking about the US
things you do differently like what when
I say to sort of what what has been one
of your sort of biggest lessons
personally for you on your own Journey
on this entrepreneurial Journey being a
leader what what what what comes to mind
sprinting at everything is not
necessarily the the best solution
um
be considered
um make sure you've got proper structure
framework
um and yeah you're happy in your life
with what you're doing there's going to
be tough patches
um
but if you've got that framework and
that support to get through it
um then you know that that's a
short-term thing
um I mean you can see at the moment
people are finding this Market a little
bit tougher
um the fish have definitely stopped
jumping into the boat but actually
we've we've done 40 growth
this q1 and we'll see in the market
still pretty strong and I think that's
foundations of having really great
relationships
um and having a happy Workforce and that
that
just maintaining that having the
awareness the understanding the skill
the experience to be honest
um it's tough to do if you haven't got
the experience and you haven't learned
from other people so learn as much as
you possibly can take as much advice as
you possibly can
um
I think that's that's probably my um
my best uh advice to myself
um but at the same time you need to be
able to cut through
the bits of advice that work you still
need to have your kind of ideology what
you stand for 100 and there was times in
the past when I kind of took advice that
was
perhaps wasn't didn't work out as well
as I would have liked
um so
experience experience yeah Roger thank
you so much it's been a pleasure it's
great to have a YouTube sensation I'm
looking forward to the boxing match
thank you so much for listening to the
episode I hope you enjoyed it and got
value from the conversation if you did
enjoy it please don't forget to like
share and subscribe and we'll see you in
the next episode